You’ve probably wondered
why the European Parliament is in Strasbourg,
but also in Brussels
– and in Luxembourg
It’s not an uncontroversial topic,
as many think it's too expensive
and not good for climate change
to keep the official seat
in this French city
while most of the work
is done in Brussels
Strasbourg initially became
the main home of the Parliament
because there was another organisation,
the Council of Europe,
which offered its planary chamber
for the very first version
of the European Parliament
As work became more and more
concentrated in Brussels,
an arrangement had to be made
In 1992, the European Council
(which is not the same
as the Council of Europe)
decided to keep Strasbourg
as the official seat
of the European Parliament
– a big win for French diplomacy
And the Parliament is
bound to meet here
12 times a year
So that's when the MEPs and their staff
come here for what's known
as plenary weeks
What else you want
to know about the EU?